we're eternals  for 7 000 years we've protected humans  from the deviants  why didn't you guys help fight thanos or  any war all the other terrible things  throughout history  we were instructed not to interfere  until now  you hear that eternal's assembled  hi  hello hey who's your gardener  this planet and these people have  changed all of us  when you love something  you protect it  for eternity  [Music]  marvel studios eternals what's your  superpower  you know that your babysitting  privileges are completely revoked  pg-13 get tickets now five years ago  thanos erased half of the universe  but the people of this planet brought  everyone back  with a snap of a finger  humanity once believed we were gods  with what this planet now faces  they will believe again  eternal's assembled  watch the planet  we fight  marvel studios eternal spray pg-13 only  appears november 5th